The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROF.
JERISON: So, we're ready
to begin Lecture 10,
and what I'm going to begin
with is by finishing up
some things from last time.
We'll talk about
approximations, and I
want to fill in a
number of comments
and get you a little bit more
oriented in the point of view
that I'm trying to express
about approximations.
So, first of all, I
want to remind you
of the actual applied example
that I wrote down last time.
So that was this business here.
There was something
from special relativity.
And the approximation that
we used was the linear
approximation, with a -1/2 power
that comes out to be T(1 + 1/2
v^2/c^2).
I want to reiterate why this
is a useful way of thinking
of things.
And why this is that this
comes up in real life.
Why this is maybe more
important than everything
that I've taught you
about technically so far.
So, first of all, what this is
telling us is the change in T
divided by T, if you do the
arithmetic here and subtract T,
that's using the change
in T is T' - T here.
If you work that out, this is
approximately the same as 1/2
v^2/c^2.
So what is this saying?
This is saying that if you
have this satellite, which
is going at speed v, and
little c is the speed of light,
then the change in the
watch down here on earth,
relative to the time
on the satellite,
is going to be proportional
to this ratio here.
So, physically,
this makes sense.
This is time divided by time.
And this is velocity squared
divided by velocity squared.
So, in each case,
the units divide out.
So this is a
dimensionless quantity.
And this is a
And the only point here
that we're trying to make
is just this notion
of proportionality.
So I want to write this down.
Just-- in summary.
So the error
fraction, if you like,
which is sort of the number
of significant digits
that we have in our measurement,
is proportional, in this case,
to this quantity.
It happens to be proportional
to this quantity here.
And the factor is,
happens to be, 1/2.
So these proportionality factors
are what we're looking for.
Their rates of change.
Their rates of
change of something
with respect to something else.
Now, on your homework,
you have something
rather similar to this.
So in Problem, on Part
2B, Part II, Problem 1,
there's the speed
of a pitch, right?
And the speed of the pitch
is changing depending
on how high the mound is.
And the point here
is that that's
approximately
proportional to the change
in the height of the mound.
In that problem, we
had this delta h,
that was the x variable
in that problem.
And what you're
trying to figure out
is what the constant
of proportionality is.
That's what you're aiming
for in this problem.
So there's a linear
relationship, approximately,
to all intents and purposes
this is an equality.
Because the lower
order terms are
unimportant for the problem.
Just as over here, this function
is a little bit complicated.
This function is a
little more simple.
For the purposes of this
problem, they are the same.
Because the errors
are negligible
for the particular problem
that we're working on.
So we might as well work with
the simpler relationship.
And similarly, over here,
so you could do this with,
in this case with
square roots, it's
not so hard here with
reciprocals of square roots.
It's also not terribly
hard to do it numerically.
And the reason why we're
not doing it numerically
is that, as I say,
this is something that
happens all across engineering.
People are looking for
these linear relationships
between the change in some input
and the change in the output.
And if you don't make
these simplifications,
then when you get, say,
a dozen of them together,
you can't figure
out what's going on.
In this case the design of the
satellite, it's very important.
The speed actually
isn't just one speed.
Because it's the relative
speed of you to the satellite.
And you might be-- it depends
on your angle of sight
with the satellite
what the speed is.
So it varies quite a bit.
So you really need
this rule of thumb.
Then there are all kinds
of other considerations
in this question.
Like, for example,
there's the fact
that we're sitting on Earth
and so we're rotating around
on what's called a
non-inertial frame.
So there's the question
of that acceleration.
There's the question that the
gravity that I experience here
on Earth is not the same
as up at the satellite.
And that also creates
a difference in time,
as a result of
general relativity.
So all of these
considerations come down
to formulas which are
this complicated or maybe
a tiny bit more.
Not really that much.
And then people simplify
them enormously to these very
simple-minded rules.
And they don't keep
track of what's going on.
So in order to
design the system,
you must make these
simplifications,
otherwise you can't even
think about what's going on.
This comes up in everything.
In weather forecasting,
economic forecasting.
Figuring out whether there's
going to be an asteroid that's
going to hit the Earth.
Every single one of
these things involves
dozens of these considerations.
OK, there was a question
that I saw, here.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROF.
JERISON: Yeah.
Basically, any
problem where you have
a derivative, the
rate of change also
depends upon what
the base point is.
That's the question.
You're saying, doesn't
this delta v also
depend, I had a base
point in that problem.
I happened to decide that
pitchers pitch on average
about 90 miles an hour.
Whereas, in fact, some pitchers
pitch at 100 miles an hour,
some pitch at 80 miles an
hour, and of course they
vary the speed of the pitch.
And so, this varies
a little bit.
In fact, that's sort of
a second order effect.
It does change the constant
of proportionality.
It's a rate of change at
a different base point.
Which we're considering fixed.
In fact, that's sort of
a second order effect.
When you actually do the
computations, what you discover
is that it doesn't make
that much difference.
To the a.
And that's something that
you get from experience.
That it turns out, which things
matter and which things don't.
And yet again, that's exactly
the same sort of consideration
but at the next order of what
I'm talking about here is.
You have to have enough
experience with numbers
to know that if you take, if
you vary something a little bit
it's not going to change
the answer that you're
looking for very much.
And that's exactly the
point that I'm making.
So I can't make them all
at once, all such points.
So that's my pitch for
understanding things
from this point of view.
Now, we're going to go on, now,
to quadratic approximations,
which are a little
more complicated.
So, we talked a little
bit about this last time
but I didn't finish.
So I want to finish this up.
And the first thing
that I should say
is that you use these when the
linear approximation is not
enough.
OK, so, that's something
that you really
need to get a little
experience with.
In economics, I told
you they use logarithms.
So sometimes they use
log-linear functions.
Sometimes they use
log-quadratic functions
when the log-linear
ones don't work.
So most modeling in economics
is with log-quadratic functions.
And if you've made it any
more complicated than that,
it's useless.
And it's a mess.
And people don't do it.
So they stick with the
quadratic ones, typically.
So the basic formula here,
and I'm going to take the base
point to be 0, is that f(x) is
approximately f(0) + f'(0) x.
That's the linear part.
Plus this extra term.
Which is f''(0)/2 x^2.
And this is supposed
to work for x near 0.
So I've chosen the base
point as simply as possible.
So here's more or less
where we left off last time.
And one thing that I said
I was going to explain,
which I will now, is
why it's 1/2 f''(0).
So we need to know that.
So let's work that
out here first of all.
So I'm just going
to do it by example.
So if you like, the
answer is just, well,
what happens when
you have a parabola?
A parabola's a quadratic.
It had better-- its quadratic
approximation had better
be itself.
It's got to be the best one.
So it's got to be itself.
So this formula, if
it's going to work,
has to work on the nose,
for quadratic functions.
So, let's take a look.
If I differentiate,
I get b + 2cx.
If I differentiate a
second time, I get 2c.
And now let's plug it in.
Well, we can recover, what is
it that we want to recover?
We want to recover
these numbers a, b and c
using the derivatives
evaluated at 0.
So let's see.
It's pretty easy, actually.
f(0) = a.
That's on the nose.
If you plug in x = 0 here, these
terms drop out and you get a.
And now, f'(0),
whoops that was wrong.
So I wrote f' but
what I meant was f.
So f(0) is a.
Let's back up.
f(0) is a, so if I
plug in x = 0 I get a.
Now, f'(0), that's
this next formula here,
f'(0), I plug in 0
here, and I get b.
That's also good.
And that's exactly what
the linear approximation
is supposed to be.
But now you notice, f'' is 2c.
So to recover c, I
better take half of it.
And that's it.
That's the reason.
There's no chance that any
other formula could work.
And this one does.
So that's the explanation
for the formula.
And now I remind you that I had
a collection of basic formulas
written on the board.
And I want to just make sure
we know all of them again.
So, first of all, there was
sine x is approximately x.
Cosine x is approximately
1 - 1/2 x^2.
And e^x is approximately
1 + x + 1/2 x^2.
So those were three that
I mentioned last time.
And, again, this is
all for x near 0.
All for x near 0 only.
These are wildly wrong far
away, but near 0 they're
nice, good, quadratic
approximations.
Now, the other
two approximations
that I want to mention
are the logarithm,
and we use the
base point shifted.
So we can put it at x near 0.
And this one - sorry, this is an
approximately equals sign there
- turns out to be x - 1/2 x^2.
And the last one is (1+x)^r,
which turns out to be 1 + rx +
r(r-1)/2 x^2.
Now, eventually, your mind
will converge on all of these
and you'll find them
relatively easy to memorize.
But it'll take some
getting used to.
And I'm not claiming that
you should recognize them
and understand them all now.
But I'm going to put a
giant box around this.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROF.
JERISON: Yes.
So the question was,
you get all of these
if you use that equation there.
That's exactly what
I'm going to do.
So I already did it actually
for these three, last time.
But I didn't do it
yet for these two.
But I will do it in
about two minutes.
Well, maybe five minutes.
But first I want to explain
just a few things about these.
They all follow from
the basic formula.
In fact, that one deserves
a pink box too, doesn't it.
That one's pretty important.
Alright.
Yeah.
Maybe even some little sparkles.
Alright.
OK.
So that's pretty important.
Almost as important as the more
basic one without this term
here.
So now, let me just tell
you a little bit more
about the significance.
Again, this is just
to reinforce something
that we've already done.
But it's closely
related to what you're
doing on your problem set.
So it's worth your
while to recall this.
So, there's this expression
that we were dealing with.
And we talked about
it in lecture.
And we showed that this tends
to e as k goes to infinity.
So that's what we
showed in lecture.
And the way that we did that
was, we took the logarithm
and we wrote it
as k times, sorry,
the logarithm of 1 + 1/k.
And then we evaluated
the limit of this.
And I want to do
this limit again,
using linear approximation.
To show you how easy it
is if you just remember
the linear approximation.
And then we'll explain where the
quadratic approximation comes
in.
So I claim that this
is approximately
equal to k times 1/k.
Now, why is that?
Well, that's just this
linear approximation.
So what did I use here?
I used log of 1+x is
approximately x, for x = 1/k.
That's what I used in
this approximation here.
And that's the
linear approximation
to the natural logarithm.
And this number is
relatively easy to evaluate.
I know how to do it.
It's equal to 1.
That's the same, well,
so where does this work?
This works where
this thing is near 0.
Which is when k is
going to infinity.
This thing is working only
when k is going to infinity.
So what it's really saying,
this approximation formula,
it's really saying that as
we go to infinity, in k,
this thing is going to 1.
As k goes to infinity.
So that's what it's saying.
That's the substance there.
And that's how we want to
use it, in many instances.
Just to evaluate limits.
We also want to realize
that it's nearby
when k is pretty large, like
100 or something like that.
Now, so that's the idea of
the linear approximation.
Now, if you want to get the
rate of convergence here,
so the rate of what's
called convergence.
So convergence means how fast
this is going towards that.
What I have to do is
take the difference.
I have to take ln a_k, and I
have to subtract 1 from it.
And I know that
this is going to 0,
and the question
is how big is this.
We want it to be very small.
And the answer
we're going to get,
so the answer just uses the
quadratic approximation.
So if I just have a little
bit more detail, then
this expression
here, in other words,
I have the next
higher-order term.
This is like 1/k,
this is like 1 / k^2.
Then I can understand
how big the difference
is between the expression
that I've got and its limit.
And so that's what's
on your homework.
This is on your problem set.
OK, so that is more or
less an explanation for one
of the things that quadratic
approximations are good for.
And I'm going to give you
one more illustration.
One more illustration.
And then we'll actually
check these formulas.
Yeah, another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROF.
JERISON: That's a very
good question here.
When they, which in
this case means maybe,
me, when I give you
a question, does one
specify whether you want to
use a linear or a quadratic
approximation.
The answer is, in
real life when you're
faced with a problem like
this, where some satellite is
orbiting and you want to
know the effects of gravity
or something like that, nobody
is going to tell you anything.
They're not even
going to tell you
whether a linear approximation
is relevant, or a quadratic
or anything.
So you're on your own.
When I give you a question,
at least for right now,
I'm always going to tell you.
But as time goes on
I'd like you to get
used to when it's
enough to get away
with a linear approximation.
And you should only use
a quadratic approximation
if somebody forces you to.
You should always start
trying with a linear one.
Because the quadratic ones are
much more complicated as you'll
see in this next example.
OK, so the example
that I want to use
is, you're going to be
stuck with it because I'm
asking for the quadratic.
So we're going to find the
quadratic approximation
near-- for x near 0.
To what?
Well, this is the
same function that we
used in the last lecture.
I think this was it.
e^(-3x) (1+x)^(-1/2).
OK.
So, unfortunately, I stuck
it in the wrong place
to be able to fit this
very long formula here.
So I'm going to switch it.
I'm just going to write it here.
And we're going to just
do the approximation.
So we're going to say
quadratic, in parentheses.
And we'll say x near 0.
So that's what I want.
So now, here's
what I have to do.
Well, I have to write in
the quadratic approximation
for e^(-3x), and I'm going to
use this formula right here.
And so that's 1 +
(-3x) + (-3x)^2 / 2.
And the other factor,
I'm going to have
to use this formula down here.
Because r is - 1/2.
And so that's 1 - 1/2 x
+ 1/2 (-1/2)(-3/2)x^2.
So this is the r term, and
this is the r - 1 term.
And now I'm going
to do something
which is the only good thing
about quadratic approximations.
They're messy, they're
long, there's nothing
particularly good about them.
But there is one good
thing about them.
Which is that you always get to
ignore the higher order terms.
So even though this looks like
a very ugly multiplication,
I can do it in my head.
Just watching it.
Because I get a 1 * 1, I'm
forced with that term here.
And then I get the cross
terms which are linear,
which is -3x - 1/2 x.
We already did that
when we calculated
the linear
approximation, so that's
this times the 1 and
this times that 1.
And now I have three cross
terms which are quadratic.
So one of them is these two
linear terms are multiplying.
So that's plus 3/2 x^2.
That's -3 times -1/2.
And then there's this
term, multiplying the 1,
that's plus 9/2 x^2.
And then there's one last term,
which is this monster here.
Multiplying 1, and that is -3/8.
So the great thing is, we
drop x^3, x^4, etc., terms.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROF.
JERISON: OK, well
so copy it down.
And you work it out
as I'm doing it now.
So what I did is, I
multiplied 1 by 1.
I'm using the
distributive law here.
That was this one.
I multiplied this 3x by this
one, that was that term.
I multiplied this by
this, that's that term.
And then I multiplied
this by this.
In other words, two x
terms that gave me an x^2
and a (-3)(-1/2).
And I'm going to
stop at that point.
Because the point is
it's just all the rest
of the terms that come up.
Now, the reason, the only
reason why it's easy,
is that I only have to
go up to x squared terms.
I don't have to do
the higher ones.
Another question, way back here.
Yeah, right there.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROF.
JERISON: OK.
So somebody can check
my arithmetic, too.
Good.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROF.
JERISON: Why do I get to drop
all the higher-order terms.
So, that's because
the situation where
I'm going to apply this is
the situation in which x is,
say, 1/100.
So here's about 1/100.
Here's something which
is on the order of 1/100.
This is on the order of 1/100^2.
1/100^2, all of these terms.
Now, these cubic and quartic
terms are of the order
of 1/100^3.
That's 10^(-6).
6.
And the point is
that I'm not claiming
that I have an exact answer.
And I'm going to drop things
of that order of magnitude.
So I'm saving everything
up to 4 decimal places.
I'm throwing away things which
are 6 decimal places out.
Does that answer your question?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROF.
JERISON: So.
That's the situation, and now
you can combine the terms.
I mean, it's not
very impressive here.
This is equal to 1 - 7/2
x, maybe, plus 51/8 x^2.
If I've made that-- if those
minus signs hadn't canceled,
I would have gotten
the wrong answer here.
Anyway.
So, this is a 2 here, sorry.
7/2.
This is the linear
approximation we got last time
and here's the extra
information that we
got from this calculation.
Which is this 51/8 term.
Right, you have to
accept that there's
a certain degree of
complexity to this problem
and the answer is
sufficiently complicated
so it can't be less
arithmetic because we
get this peculiar
51/8 there, right.
So one of the
things to realize is
that these kinds of problems,
because they involve
many, many terms
are always going
to involve a little bit
of complicated arithmetic.
Last little bit,
I did promise you
that I was going to derive
these two relations, as I said.
Did the ones in the left column.
So let's carry that out.
And as someone just pointed out,
it all comes from this formula
here.
So let's just check it.
So we'll start with
the log function.
This is the function, f,
and then f' is 1/(1+x).
And f'', so this is f', this
is f'', is - -1 / (1+x)^2.
And now I have to plug in x = 0.
So at x = 0 this is
ln 1, which is 0.
So this is at x = 0.
I'm getting 0 here, I
plug in 0 and I get 1.
And here, I plug
in 0 and I get -1.
So now I go and I look
up at that formula,
which is way in that
upper corner there.
And I see that the coefficient
on the constant is 0.
The coefficient on x is 1.
And then the other coefficient,
the very last one, is -1/2.
So this is the -1 here.
And then in the formula,
there's a 2 in the denominator.
So it's half of whatever I get
for this second derivative,
at 0.
So this is the
approximation formula, which
is way up in that corner there.
Similarly, if I
do it for (1+x)^r,
I have to differentiate
that, I get r(1+x)^(r-1),
and then r(r-1)(x+1)^(r-2).
So here are the derivatives.
And so if I evaluate
them at x = 0, I get 1.
That's 1^r is 1.
And here I get r.
1^(r-1) times r.
And here, I plug in x
= 0 and I get r(r-1).
So again, the pattern
is right above it here.
The 1 is there, the r is there.
And then instead of
r(r-1), I have half that.
For the coefficient.
So these are just examples.
Obviously if we had a
more complicated function,
we might carry this out.
But as a practical
matter, we try
to stick with the
ones in the pink box
and just use algebra
to get other formulas.
So I want to shift gears now
and treat the subject that was
supposed to be this lecture.
And we're not quite
caught up, but we
will try to do our best to
do as much as we can today.
So the next topic
is curve sketching.
And so let's get
started with that.
So now, happily in this
subject, there are more pictures
and it's a little
bit more geometric.
And there's relatively
little computation.
So let's hope we can do this.
So I want to-- so
here we go, we'll
start with curve sketching.
And the goal here--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROF.
JERISON: So that's like
'liner', the last time.
That's kind of sketchy
spelling, isn't it?
Yeah, there are certain kinds
of things which I can't spell.
But, all right.
Sketching.
Alright.
So here's our goal.
Our goal is to draw the
graph of f, using f' and f''.
Whether they're
positive or negative.
So that's it.
This is the goal here.
However, there is a big warning
that I want to give you.
And this is one
that unfortunately
I now have to make you
unlearn, especially
those that you
that have actually
had a little bit of
calculus before, I
want to make you unlearn
some of your instincts
that you developed.
So this will be harder
for those of you who
have actually done this before.
But for the rest of you,
it will be relatively easy.
Which is, don't abandon
your precalculus skills.
And common sense.
So there's a great deal
of common sense in this.
And it actually trumps
some of the calculus.
The calculus just fills in
what you didn't quite know yet.
So I will try to
illustrate this.
And because we're
running a bit late,
I won't get to the some
of the main punchlines
until next lecture.
But I want you to do it.
So for now, I'm just
going to tell you
about the general principles.
And in the process I'm going
to introduce the terminology.
Just, the words that we
need to use to describe what
is that we're doing.
And there's also
a certain amount
of carelessness with that
in many of the treatments
that you'll see.
And a lot of hastiness.
So just be a little patient
and we will do this.
So, the first principle
is the following.
If f' is positive,
then f is increasing.
That's a straightforward
idea, and it's closely related
to this tangent
line approximation
or the linear approximation
that I just did.
You can just imagine.
Here's the tangent line,
here's the function.
And if the tangent
line is pointing up,
then the function is
also going up, too.
So that's all that's
going on here.
Similarly, if f' is negative,
then f is decreasing.
And that's the basic idea.
Now, the second step is
also fairly straightforward.
It's just a second-order
effect of the same type.
If you have f'' as positive,
then that means that f' is
increasing.
That's the same principle
applied one step up.
Right?
Because if f'' is positive,
that means it's the derivative
of f'.
So it's the same
principle just repeated.
And now I just want to
draw a picture of this.
Here's a picture of it, I claim.
And it looks like
something's going down.
And I did that on purpose.
But there is something
that's increasing here.
Which is, the slope is
very steep negative here.
And it's less steep
negative over here.
So we have the slope which is
some negative number, say, -4.
And here it's -3.
So it's increasing.
It's getting less negative,
and maybe eventually it'll
curve up the other way.
And this is a picture of
what I'm talking about here.
That's what it means to
say that f' is increasing.
The slope is getting larger.
And the way to describe a curve
like this is that it's concave.
So f is concave up.
And similarly, f'' negative is
going to be the same thing as f
concave-- or implies
f concave down.
So those are the ways in
which derivatives will help us
qualitatively to draw graphs.
But as I said
before, we still have
to use a little bit of common
sense when we draw the graphs.
These are just the
additional bits of help
that we have from calculus.
In drawing pictures.
So I'm going to go
through one example
to introduce all the notations.
And then eventually, so probably
at the beginning of next time,
I'll give you a
systematic strategy
that's going to work when
what I'm describing now
goes wrong, or a
little bit wrong.
So let's begin with a
straightforward example.
So, the first example that I'll
give you is the function f(x) =
3x - x^3.
Just, as I said, to be able to
introduce all the notations.
Now, if you differentiate
it, you get 3 - 3x^2.
And I can factor that.
This is 3 (1-x) (1+x).
OK?
And so, I can decide
whether the derivative
is positive or negative.
Easily enough.
Namely, just staring at this,
I can see that when -1 < x < 1,
in that range there, both these
numbers, both these factors,
are positive.
1-x is a positive number and
1 1+x is a positive number.
So, in this range,
f'(x) is positive.
So this thing is,
so f is increasing.
And similarly, in
the other ranges,
if x is very, very
large, this becomes,
if it crosses 1, in
fact, this becomes,
this factor becomes negative
and this one stays positive.
So when x > 1, we have
that f'(x) is negative.
And so f is decreasing.
And the same thing goes
for the other side.
When it's less than -1,
that also works this way.
Because when it's less than
-1, this factor is positive.
But the other one is negative.
So in both of these cases,
we get that it's decreasing.
So now, here's the schematic
picture of this function.
So here's -1, here's 1.
It's going to go down, up, down.
That's what it's doing.
Maybe I'll just leave
it alone like this.
That's what it looks like.
So, this is the
kind of information
we can get right off the bat.
And you notice immediately
that it's very important,
from the features of
the function, the sort
of key features of the
function that we see here,
are these two places.
Maybe I'll even mark
them in a, like this.
And these things
are turning points.
So what are they?
Well, they're just
the points where
the derivative changes sign.
Where it's negative here
and it's positive there,
so there it must be 0.
So we have a definition, and
this is the most important
definition in this subject,
which is that is if f'(x_0) =
0, we call x_0 a critical point.
The word 'turning point' is not
used just because, in fact, it
doesn't have to turn
around at those points.
But certainly, if it turns
around then this will happen.
And we also have
another notation,
which is the number
y_0 which is f(x_0) is
called a critical value.
So these are the key
numbers that we're
going to have to work out
in order to understand
what the function looks like.
So what I'm going to
do is just plot them.
We're going to plot the
critical points and the values.
Well, we found the critical
points relatively easily.
I didn't write it down here
but it's pretty obvious.
If you set f(x) = 0,
that implies that (1 -
x)(1 + x) = 0, which implies
that x is plus or minus 1.
So those are known as
the critical points.
And now, in order to get
the critical values here,
I have to plug in f(1), for
instance, the function is 3x -
x^2, so there's this 3
* 1 - 1^3, which is 2.
And f(-1), which is 3(-1)
- (-1)^3, which is -2.
And so I can plot
the function here.
So here's the point -1
and here's, up here, is 2.
So this is-- whoops,
which one is it?
Yeah.
This is -1, so it's down here.
So it's (-1, -2).
And then over here, I
have the point (1, 2).
Alright, now, what
information do
I get from - so I've now
plotted two, I claim,
very interesting points.
What information
do I get from this?
The answer is, I know
something very nearby.
Because I've already
checked that the thing
is coming down from the
left, and coming back up.
And so it must be
shaped like this.
Over here.
The tangent line is 0, it's
going to be level there.
And similarly over here,
it's going to do that.
So this is what we know so far,
based on what we've computed.
Question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROF.
JERISON: The question
is, what happens
if there's a sharp corner.
The answer is,
calculus is-- it's not
called a critical point.
It's a something else.
And it's a very
important point, too.
And we will be discussing
those kinds of points.
There are much more
dramatic instances of that.
That's part of what
we're going to say.
But I just want to
save that, all right.
We will be discussing.
Yeah.
Question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] PROF.
JERISON: The question
that was asked
was, how did I know
at the critical point
that it's concave down over
here and concave up over here.
The answer is that
I actually did not
use the second derivative yet.
What I used is another
piece of information.
I used the information
that I derived over here.
That f' is positive,
where f' is positive
and where it's negative.
So what I know is that
the graph is going down
to the left of -1.
It's going up to
the right, here.
It's going up here and
it's going down there.
I did not use the
second derivative.
I used the first derivative.
OK, but I didn't
just use the fact
that there was a
turning point here.
So, actually, I
was using the fact
that it was a turning point.
I wasn't using the fact that
it had the second derivative,
though.
OK.
For now.
You can also see it by the
second derivative as well.
So now, the next thing
that I'd like to do,
I need to finish off this graph.
And I just want to do it a
little bit carefully here.
In the order that is reasonable.
Now, you might happen
to notice, and there's
nothing wrong with this.
So let's even fill in a guess.
In order to fill in a
guess, though, and have
it be even vaguely
right, I do have
to notice that
this thing crosses,
this function
crosses the origin.
The function f(x) = 3x -
x^3 happens to also have
the property that f(0) = 0.
Again, common sense.
You're allowed to use
your common sense.
You're allowed to notice a value
of the function and put it in.
So there's nothing
wrong with that.
If you happen to
have such a value.
So, now we can guess what our
function is going to look like.
It's going to maybe
come down like this.
Come up like this.
And come down like this.
That could be what
it looks like.
But, you know,
another possibility
is it sort of comes along
here and goes out that way.
Comes along here and goes
out that way, who knows?
It happens, by the way,
that it's an odd function.
Right?
Those are all odd powers.
So, actually, it's
symmetric on the right half
and the left half.
And crosses at 0.
So everything that
we do on the right
is going to be the same as
what happens on the left.
That's another piece
of common sense.
You want to make
use of that as much
as possible, whenever
you're drawing anything.
Don't want to throw
out information.
So this function
happens to be odd.
Odd, and f(0) = 0.
I'm considering those to be
kinds of precalculus skills
that I want you to use
as much as you can.
So now, here's the
first feature which
is unfortunately ignored in
most discussions of functions.
And it's strange,
because nowadays we
have graphing things.
And it's really the only
part of the exercise
that you couldn't do, at least
on this relatively simpleminded
level, with a
graphing calculator.
And that is what I would
call the ends of the problem.
So what happens off the
screen, is the question.
And that basically is the
theoretical part of the problem
that you have to address.
You can program this.
You can draw all the
pictures that you want.
But what you won't see
is what's off the screen.
You need to know
something to figure out
what's off the screen.
So, in this case, I'm talking
about what's off the screen
going to the right,
or going to the left.
So let's check the ends.
So here, let's just take a look.
We have the function f(x),
which is, sorry, 3x - x^3.
Again this is a
precalculus sort of thing.
And we're imagining
now, let's just
do x goes to plus infinity.
So what happens here.
When x is gigantic, this term
is completely negligible.
And it just behaves like -x^3,
which goes to minus infinity
as x goes to plus infinity.
And similarly, f(x)
goes to plus infinity
if x goes to minus infinity.
Now let me pull down this
picture again, and show you
what piece of the
information we've got.
We now know that it is
heading up this way.
It doesn't go like this,
it goes up like that.
And I'm going to
put an arrow for it,
And it's going down like this.
Heading down to minus
infinity as x goes out farther
to the right.
And going out to plus infinity
as x goes farther to the left.
So now there's
hardly anything left
of this function to describe.
There's really nothing left
except maybe decoration.
And we kind of like
that decoration,
so we will pay attention to it.
And to do that, we'll have to
check the second derivative.
So if we differentiate a second
time, the first derivative was,
remember, 3 - 3x^2.
So the second derivative is -6x.
So now we notice that f''(x)
is negative if x is positive.
And f''(x) is positive
if x is negative.
And so in this part
it's concave down.
And in this part
it's concave up.
And now I'm going to switch the
boards so that you'll, and draw
it.
And you see that it was
begging to be this way.
So we'll fill in
the rest of it here.
Maybe in a nice color here.
So this is the whole graph
and this is the correct graph.
It comes down in one swoop
down here, and comes up here.
And then it changes to concave
down right at the origin.
So this point is of
interest, not only
because it's the place
where it crosses the axis,
but it's also what's
called an inflection point.
Inflection point,
that's a point where--
because f'' at that
place is equal to 0.
So it's a place where the
second derivative is 0.
We also consider those
to be interesting points.
Now, so let me just making
one closing remark here.
Which is that all of this
information fits together.
And we're going to have much,
much harder examples of this
where you'll actually have to
think about what's going on.
But there's a lot of
stuff protecting you.
And functions will
behave themselves
and turn around appropriately.
Anyway, we'll talk
about it next time.